whenever you're filming at a frame rate
faster than your playback frame rate you
get slow motion for example if I film a
thousand frames a second but play it
back at 25 it stretches every second of
real time to be 40 seconds long however
if you film exactly 90 000 frames a
second
it stretches one second of real time to
be exactly an hour long every time you
see this clock in the top right of the
screen you're looking at time as if it
took an entire hour for just one second
to pass this is part two
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and there we go hopefully you enjoyed
part two part one is in the description
let me know if you'd like to see a part
three and in the meantime you can check
out the entire raw file of Dan getting
beamed in the head by a football and 90
000 frames a second
thanks for watching